we are live
we are in the building
and we are
announcing [ __ ] uh let me just let
people get in here warm it up
warm it up warm it up dave on periscope
what's good or
twitter live yummy food world hi hi
hash bastards nfts
big shout out to hash bastards nfts if
you can't afford to be
friends tomorrow
go check out hash bastards nft great art
i kind of like it a lot one of my
favorite things and one of the things
i'm most excited about
after this big drop is obviously i've
gotta
after it happens gotta take some money
off the eth for the taxes
and then a bunch of it the majority of
it for
vcon and then for the
20 to 50 person staff to build out the
characters
but then i'm gonna go buy some art from
a lot of the emerging artists that i
fall in love with in the nft space
i'm here to officially announce
uh some exciting news i will be
launching the friends auction
tomorrow so tomorrow
at 5 55
p.m eastern time uh we will be launching
befriends.com
couple things number one one thing i've
absolutely learned
is uh uh dustin if you could just add
dot com to the beat friends thing on
there
and then pin it it was awesome thank you
brother one thing i've definitely
learned is um
web 3 launches just on be a top shot
push
two hours today i've seen a lot of stuff
it's hard it's hard [ __ ] and so i'm
really excited about it
i just want to thank everybody nameless
on my team
most of all obviously to andy k who's
been my right hand throughout this
entire project
um i'm really excited tomorrow
5 55 pm et
actually the first thing i'm going to do
is buy a bunch of jordan rookies and a
chart another charizard hold on
then i'm gonna buy some nftr
and then i'm gonna sleep um
really excited please pass it on a
couple of notes one i've adjusted some
prices
so i'll be talking about that in my
discord please right now if you're
watching share the discord link
what a community has been born 150 000
people almost
on discord jamming the last week
family people teaching each other about
ethereum nfts
minting gas custodial non-custodial
mobile
chrome metamask rainbow [ __ ]
just incredible big shout out huge shout
out
massive shout out to the v friends
discord
number two highly recommend that you go
with
laptop chrome metamask best experience
right now
as we're bug testing mobile safari
is a little tricky like we've gotten it
there enough that i feel great about it
for tomorrow uh one of the better
experiences compared to what i've seen
but
you know there's some incredible
platforms out there bitsky
big shout out you know just tons nifty
and gateway and and open c and
wearable there's so much great stuff
going on in the space
um artifact but we built our own [ __ ] on
top of this incredible platform
called nameless that you'll get to know
which will not be
nameless after tomorrow please go to the
bottom of the website immediately
when you see it tomorrow befriends.com
auction starts tomorrow
um i'm passing on a bunch of information
please pass it on
i really like the the laptop chrome
metamask rainbow's working sweet
rainbow's [ __ ] epic looks awesome too
you know what the best part about
rainbow is it looks sweet in your
rainbow just pulling up mine right now
like look how epic my avastars look
in there right it looks cool it's not
like
the the design is just amazing don't
sleep
purple hat gang what oh what oh do i own
the punks i have the punks
one day people will talk about the
friends the way to talk about punks not
really the punk's the og [ __ ] but i'm
gonna [ __ ] do some damage
i've been working behind the scenes to
build out these characters i am
launching my smurfs my
scooby-doo my hello kitty
that is loaded with three years of
padding
with v-con and one-on-one experiences
that have
hopefully show influencers and
celebrities a way to do it more than
just put out a scribble
and try to sell some [ __ ] really excited
please pass it on people have been
waiting big day for me tomorrow
um please join the discord discord dot
gg slash befriends
uh and i am incredibly fired up uh
if you're buying for the first time when
those wallets connect there's like a
little bit of a delay
this is not web 2 where everything's
like boom boom boom boom boom
there's no stripe integration that [ __ ]
gets scary
first time you're selling just you spend
your eighth where's my be friend
you know um but we'll be we'll be
community managing
we'll be in the discord troubleshooting
um
uh izzy's asking for the discord discord
is discord dot gg slash v
friends it's scrolling right here it's
linked everywhere the discord is linked
to my instagram and my
uh uh twitter account i highly recommend
you get in
um it's really really a big deal i see a
lot of people asking questions
you know a lot of people have not been
following along this last two weeks
please go to befriends.com please go to
the discord
you will find out information i'm trying
to read the chat right now
yeah the discord is amazing uh robin
anderson be friends
is an intellectual property that i'm
building that i want to be my
star wars that i want to be my
wwf that i want to be my
thundercats it's an intellectual
property around characters that have the
traits that i'm most passionate about
patient panda
empathy elephant things like that
that i'm gonna build out oh very nice
here is the friends.com page right now
where you can get all the information
watch the video
on top of which every befriend token
gives you
a ticket you can show this to dustin
vcon.co co um
which i'm excited about so i'm really
excited
you have to go into the discord that's
where all the action is that's where all
the learning is please go there
it's on another level um and tomorrow at
5
55 p.m they launch the
floor it's a dutch auction i'm starting
price
uh i've got a pretty big announcement
here decided to drop it from 3e to 2.5
as a starting price it could go all the
way down to 0.5 if they don't sell out
0.5 each is the floor for v friends
which
don't forget not only is it collectible
which i hopefully can
take to the moon it also comes with the
conference tickets and then there's a
whole layer of access tickets gift goats
some super premium stuff go to
befriends.com right now to learn the
whole thing
uh able it's not confusing go to
befriends.com
and uh and i'm
super fired up i'm uh i'm really excited
5 55
p.m et tomorrow eastern
people have already started
tattooing the characters somebody said
i'm gonna get the first tattoo too late
hungry hammer shark hammerhead shark
hammerhead hungry hammerhead
lot going on and uh
i'm really excited please check it out
we'll see all of you tomorrow
we'll be talking all tonight all night
tonight on discord all day tomorrow
i have some in-depth interviews with
kevin rose
with bankless there's some good
interviews on what i'm doing
some cnbc some cnn some all that
a lot of sleepless nights big shout out
to my whole team
big day tomorrow really excited and also
if 0.5 if it doesn't hit the floor the
0.5 eth
on the tokens please go to befriends.com
to learn the whole game
uh i will be giving away um
many tokens on the discord uh great
question jason
if this is a five-day five-day launch
event
because i don't want the whales coming
in and buying everything um right away i
was a little worried about that that's
why i did the
dutch auction started the cap dropped it
down um
big stuff really excited about that five
day event
about almost 50 percent
drop tomorrow i'll give you the exact
numbers tomorrow
48.72 of the tokens are being dropped
the twelfth 19.96 there will be a
20-hour auction
at 5 50 p.m 5 55 p.m if somebody grabs
it it's a dutch auction so you want to
grab the one you want to grab
because somebody grabs it's gone it's
not bidding up it's been down the second
i launched the prices started coming
down
you grab it it's a 20 hour auction
there's a four hour grace period and we
start it all again
five days tomorrow 48.72 of the auction
the following day 19.96 percent of the
auction
11.80 of the auction then on the 14th
9.78 and finally on the 59.74
about 10 the last two days of the
auction but
really excited secondary starts right
away open see all that
for all those characters i'm really just
damn excited about it
um tons of giveaways
or because the prices aren't expensive
because of the three-year conference
super conference that could be no joke
looking to do coachella meets davos
speeds like i'm looking for one of the
great conferences
and then just trying to build one of the
best intellectual properties in the
world
i'm on it i'm focused i'm ready for this
i was built for this moment this is my
career
the discord is discord dot gg slash v
friends
charlie um but the discord is linked
currently on my instagram
and on my twitter the discord is
linked to my twitter and
to my
instagram and twitter a lot of questions
i see in here
thefriends.comefriends.com if you're
watching
it's linked right here the auction
starts tomorrow 5 55 p.m
you're [ __ ] ready i'm really excited
about it
see what happens uh i'm gonna do a ton
of giveaways i held back
many tokens so i could give away more
um
sean i'm there you know
we're thinking through read the faqs all
the faqs has a lot of this stuff on some
of the
more in-depth questions
uh the only way you can get into b con
please go to bcom.com
if you can throw that up right now
dustin vcon if everybody who's watching
right now if you can just tweet out or
wherever you're in social just type it
out vcon
dot co you can watch the uh conference
video
which will be in 2022 2023 and 2024 and
if you buy of the
friend token that is your admission to
that conference
you can go to the first year sell it uh
after that
there's a lot of ways to play this my
focus is to build out the intellectual
property
of the project please please please
please please please have your eat ready
i have your metamask rainbow
non-custodial i love all of you guys
please get into the discord if you know
please get into the discord it's
bcon.com.com
please to the chord
linked in my twitter and my instagram
let me see if people are coming in there
let's see if you've got intros going
see how the intros are going here people
coming in
into the discord promise it's worth it
and that is what is going on
i am out and going back to work qa
still many little bugs uh
highly recommend laptop
chrome metamask it's just
blazing others rainbows as well
um the mobile is a [ __ ] challenge
boy [ __ ] but it works
but it's a little you know so we're
going to be up all night making it
smoother smoother smoother
some of the images will slow you know
you guys are all going to hit it hard
so this server we feel good but
looking at zed looking at nba top shots
it's people
years lots of engineers so
we can hopefully handle it please be
prepared
get educated gas fees if you don't get
the one you want
your gas is spent get educated
uh and that's the sweep so
that's a scoop uh
you can see all of you can't see
instagram because i'm on streamyard so
big shout out to everybody on instagram
everybody else is here i love you guys
um
and much love much super duper love
so we will see you tomorrow
5 55 eastern
share share share get your homies ready
thank you so much i'll see you in the
discord along there right now
love you see you bye
you